(Archer panting)
(rock music)
- Rampage!
(Lana scoffs)
- Sterling Malory Archer
- [Male] Code name Duchess.
- So here's the thing, I need to access
my operations account, and
you're preventing that.
Now we can do this easy,
or we can do it hard.
- The thought of being
dead gives you an erection?
- Jesus Christ!
- Your call.
(glass shatters)
- Woo, hoo, hoo hoo!
- [Group] Drink, drink, drink!
- Oh, oh, ow, ow!
Bawk, bawk.
- Archer!
- I'm coming!
Phasing, move!
(screams)
- Okay, let's try that again (screaming).
Survey says.
(gunshot)
(man screaming)
- Don't try to do anything stupid.
- I don't have to try.
(grunts)
(screams)
I'll show you who's boss!
How do you like that?
- Hey, asshole!
- Lana.
Lana
(dishes smashing)
Lana!
- What?!
- Danger Zone.
- Sterling Archer, I'd like you
to meet your daughter, Abijean.
- Why is that hoo named like me?
- Because he's your son!
You colossal idiot.
- Until you can look at your mother,
and see her not just as your mother,
but as a person.
- When have I ever been
honest with Sterling?
- [Burt] You can't grow up.
(baby wailing)
- Honey, you still got it.
Bow chicka bow bow, ah huh huh!
(explosion)
- Pretty much my whole life,
my default setting has been half-ass.
Woo hoo camp!
Imagine as I literally beat you to death,
that a giant hand has turned my dial
from half-ass to quadruple-ass.
(screams)
(machine gun firing)
(gunshots)
- Boo-ya kachow!
I've been shot, stabbed,
set on fire, poisoned,
shot, sexually assaulted,
partially chewed,
shot, and declared legally dead,
twice on the same day.
- I think you might have a problem.
- Yeah Lana, it's called cancer.
- [Lana] Archer?
- Are you?
- The man who cheated death?
I might be immortal.
(group screams)
- (laughing) This close.
♪ Rebound ♪
(sighs)